[Music]
do you know why you're here to me
mistakes for me just so you know
whatever you share with me in this room
stays in this room this is a safe space
so no bugs bugs listening devices Oh No
greetings fellow humans what you are
about to see is a historical record of
my life as a detective I live in the
shadow of this water tower in Portland
Oregon a place where things get strange
I am the CEO of my own detective agency
he's so fascinating I could show you
around the precinct sometimes I don't
collaborate with law enforcement okay I
have a partner that's Cole who's that
the same is total he's a 1500 pound to
pull a bear whoa I'm serious
mother not now Timmy the failure mobile
commands the respect of others it
belongs to my mother who won it in a
church brothel it was the key to my
success until it was stolen mistakes
were made
finding the failure mobile is now our
top priority he's fired up today I know
it's so exciting
I need help you always get me into
trouble can I help you you like this big
original beard if you love what you do
you gotta fight for it
brother I need my office space
my name is sillier to me failure
the name is misleading because I am
anything but I am only concerning this
one saying
previous
mistakes for me
[Music]